holding a tablet that was written
thousands of years ago and being able to
read what it says it's an amazing
feeling if you see a uniform tablet for
the first time you're not likely to
identify it as writing and you certainly
wouldn't know which way up it went it's
a form of time travel it catapults you
back in time thousands of years and puts
you directly into the shoes of somebody
who lived so many years before us
[Laughter]
the earliest known form of writing is
called cuneiform
first used over 5000 years ago it's
believed to predate egyptian hieroglyphs
cuneiform was used by civilizations that
lived in mesopotamia
several societies used cuneiform as
their writing system including the
sumerians and the acadians
pressed onto clay cuneiform tablets are
incredibly durable they're literally
fire proof but for thousands of years no
one was able to translate them
after much trial and error cuneiform
script was finally deciphered in the
victorian era
what they revealed was extraordinary
once cuneiform was deciphered
lots of unexpected things came to light
but probably
none which had greater impact than the
discovery by george smith in 1872
of the 11th tablet of the epic of
gilgamesh in which he encountered for
the first time the flood story
finding an ancient tablet with the story
of noah's ark written hundreds of years
before the bible shattered the
victorians understanding of the world
when it arrived it was a huge bang thing
like that it was a very explosive matter
and the parallel was much more than a
sort of general similarity with a boat
and water and animals it was in the same
order and there were many close points
that compellingly showed that this same
story had been current in mesopotamia a
millennium before
the earliest date when the hebrew text
is likely to have come into existence
it wasn't easy being a woman in
mesopotamia but women in wealthy
families were treated fairly well
the first known author in all of
recorded history is actually a woman the
acadian priestess and hedgehog
the case of ven herdwana shows us that
women could reach extremely high and
important positions in mesopotamian
religion
we learn a lot about society about
beliefs relations between husband and
wife business transactions going wrong
we know from uniform tablets that women
had agency we have contracts where they
are allowed to buy houses and they
retain control of their dowry they can
run and manage businesses in their own
right as long as alongside their
husbands
if you've ever wondered why there's 60
seconds in a minute or 360 degrees in a
circle it's because the sumerians and
acadians used a numbering system that
was sexagesimal which means that they
counted on a base of 60 and divisions of
60 and multiplications by 60 where we
tend to use the decimal system our own
time measurement into 60 seconds in a
minute and 60 minutes in an hour is a
direct inheritance from mesopotamian
scholarly tradition it's amazing how
many concepts we take for granted in our
modern society can actually be found for
the first time in ancient mesopotamia
the whole concept of mathematical models
the very idea that you can use data to
predict things happening in the future
and that's foundational to all modern
science
the mesopotamians were keen letter
writers sending sealed messages with
traders and travellers
reading these letters today you realize
that in many ways not that much has
changed
we can see that there were specific
formulae that were used in the
correspondence as we start an email
today by i hopeful as well they also
started with specific formulae but when
when they were angry they forgot about
this formulaic convention and they just
started the letter
very matter-of-factly as well as writing
about stock levels taxes and receipts on
their tablets cuneiform writers loved to
gossip we do have letters from these
women complaining that the men are not
sending enough money home
we have a certain sense of keeping up
with the joneses next doors built an
extension to their house when are we
going to have the money to build an
extension to our house so these kinds of
things really do come through and we see
these little human concerns these little
human squabbles
desires jealousies
and so on
by studying the past we learn so much
about ourselves and the world that we
live in
but the secrets revealed in cuneiform
tablets are only known to us today
because of clay's durability
the way we record things is constantly
evolving
technological progress means things
become obsolete very quickly
the messages we send every day are
stored in the cloud how likely is it
that anyone will be able to read that in
20 years let alone a few thousand years
there is a project in austria which is
inscribing 1 000 of the most important
books of our era onto ceramic tablets so
humanity has really come full circle
from writing on clay at the very
beginning of history to writing on clay
again in a different way to preserve our
information now
there are many initiatives trying to
prevent digital data from being lost
could it be that despite all the
incredible technology we have at our
fingertips
ancient methods of recording information
are the best way of preserving our
secrets for generations to come
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video